earlier in the week I talked about a
study that was done by the
administrators and retirement plan
professionals translation financial
nerds did the research and they did
research to figure out what the number
one indicator of people having money in
their 401k is is it the rate of return
of their investment is it the expenses
of their investment is that the
Commission's paid to their broker that
keeps them from building wealth is it
the fact that they were so smart that
they di why'd everything and did it with
I'm saying that sarcastically and did it
all with no loads because they read
money magazine and don't have a brain is
it all of these you know false things
that float around about investing now I
got to tell you if you had asked me with
the number one indicator of people
building wealth in their 401k I would
have said rate of return how much how
much return does the investment yield
when you're investing in a single stock
whether you're investing in mutual funds
whether you're investing in you know
your because the difference in compound
interest on a on a money market account
averaging two percent for the last two
decades versus a good mutual fund
averaging twelve percent for the last
several decades the difference in the
compound interest on that is
astronomical I mean I know the math the
curve on that the exponential
progression it's called it just blows
your mind there's a math person what the
difference is so I would have said the
rate of return because the difference in
the rate of return at eight percent
versus twelve percent
you'd think that's like 1/4 more it's
not it's like double triple more and so
it's crazy how much rate of return
matters mathematically so had you asked
me what the number one indicator of
someone retiring with wealth in their
401k and IRA I would have said rate of
return and I would have been wrong you
know what the number one indicator of
people that I brought this up earlier in
the week you know the number one
indicator
of people retiring wealthiest 74% of the
indication savings rate translation
putting money into the account because
all this discussion about mathematics
doesn't matter if you don't put any
freaking money into your retirement
account you become you just become one
of these math nerds where you sit around
do analysis and discuss the philosophy
of the philosophies of the financial
planning world whether we do fee-based
or is in now there's a conflict of
interest when there's a commission and
all is bunch off all right ibed up
malarkey
it's just baloney and everybody gets all
the fiduciary responsibilities that's
just horse crap when it comes down to it
this detailed piece of research revealed
something that I I know it and it's a
common-sense thing and you kind of when
you see it then you go duh but I
wouldn't have guessed it to be the
primary indicator by such a wide margin
74% of the reason people retire with
dignity is cuz they save money they
invest money the money that you put in
the steadiness and the consistency and
the amount of money you put into the
account is what causes it so in other
words people that put in 1% of their
income versus people that put in for 11%
of their income it's more than 11 times
that they get out of that if they do it
11 versus 1 a lot more because that's
what gets the compound interest no ball
rolling and I'm just going free Kitab
vyas but you know what financial nerds
and I'm I got to admit I'm a bit of a
financial I'm a lot of a financial nerd
I'm a recovering financial nerd that's
what I am trying to use wisdom and
common sense in the midst of an
academically paralyzed industry math
math nerds on steroids
I mean paralysis of the analysis beyond
belief is the financial world because we
all sit in class with our little present
value calculators and
and just you know go bananas with our
brain work instead of just going you
know what the number one key to helping
people if I'm gonna help you in other
words get rich for retirement the best
thing I can do is get you to save money
if I can get you to save money it's the
number one indicator that you're gonna
retire with dignity because your savings
rate if I can get you to do your Roth
IRAs get you to do your 401k get you out
of debt so that you can do that get your
emergency fund in place so you don't go
and cash the stupid thing out once it's
going because you have an emergency and
didn't have an emergency fund keep you
from borrowing against your 401k keep
you from cashing them out to pay off
debt keep you investing in investing and
investing and investing and investing
and investing and investing and
investing investing if I can do that for
you as your teacher as one of the people
who influences how you think about money
I've touched the number one thing that
causes you I mean I could teach you
about the details of mutual funds and
expense ratios I can teach you about how
to look at rates of return and track
record I can teach you about no load
versus load I can teach you about 12 b1
fees we can get out of prospectus and
put everybody to sleep and read through
a mutual fund prospectus and you drive
off the road falling asleep I can do all
of that and none of that causes you to
build wealth the number one thing 74
percent of the reason that people win
with money in their investments is they
actually put money into the investment
and so $100 a month invested at 12% from
age 25 to age 65 is on average going to
come out at 12%
one million one hundred and seventy six
thousand dollars so I said that the
other day on the air
lady tweeted this morning fabulous tweet
she says so I was trying to explain this
to a friend of mine and he says yeah but
a million dollars isn't gonna be worth
that much in 30 years forty years it's a
40 year example now this is the dumbest
response that you could possibly give to
someone who's telling you now listen to
that listen to this someone's telling
you $100 a month invested from age 25 to
age 65 is one million one hundred
seventy six thousand dollars
and the idiots response is but a million
dollars isn't gonna be worth that much
in 40 years let me tell you what it's
worth more than you're going to have
because you're such a [ __ ] that you
look at that example and you go well
million dollars is gonna be worth
anything so what am I gonna do nothing
and when you do nothing with your
investing you know what you have nothing
because you know what the number one
indicator if you having money and well
that retirement is that you put some
freaking money in the account instead
you go well it's not gonna be worth
anything and you sit around me welcome
what kind of moronic responses that
loser responds of course a million
dollars in 40 years is not worth what a
million dollars is now inflation will
eat the value of it but it's gonna be
worth a whole heck of a lot more then
you're gonna have because you put
nothing in because you said a million
dollars in worth anything so your
example doesn't matter so I'm not
putting any I don't want a million
dollars because a million dollars didn't
cool well no you might need 10 million
I'm good with that
but you're not gonna have it with that
attitude golly it's scary how stupid
people are man it's scary it's like
here's how you have a million dollars
yeah but a million dollars in you owe me
that much mean or is it that much now by
the way let me help you with that
million dollars isn't that much not
gonna be that much in 40 years it's
gotta be more than you have you [ __ ]
that's the answer but you know employed
company I can say it on the radio but
you're not gonna look at somebody and go
you know you're just too stupid to talk
to your parents or cousins oh my gosh
you know I mean you just really don't do
that imply company you don't just sit
and look at your friend who's an idiot
and call them that unless you're like
best friends and then it probably still
doesn't work out so but I mean what a
moronic statement I'm not gonna save
money because there's inflation
maybe that's the actual reason you
should be saving money because there's
inflation because let me help you with
this inflation ain't gonna help your
social insecurity check because it's not
keeping up with inflation
yeah try making a great life for
yourself on 900 bucks a month and see
how that works for you if you order in
that cookbook 72 ways to prepare Alpo
and love it so don't make moronic
statements when people are teaching you
about wealth like it's not good enough
it's just it's dumber than a grubworm in
a box of rocks man
I'll tell you what
[Music]
you
[Music]